hi I'm Nick Offerman
you might know me from the hit show
Parks and Recreation and your spouse
knows me from his or her sexual
fantasies I think it's time we got back
to a more old-fashioned more personal
more American Way of communication and
that's why I'm proud to introduce my new
line of handcrafted solid wood emojis
each of my emojis is lovingly carved out
of solid oak is about a foot in diameter
and weighs in the neighborhood of 14
pounds communicating with my solid wood
emojis is just like using regular emojis
but much much harder just carry the
emojis you want to do is in a large
industrial sack along with the necessary
tools then find the person you want to
communicate with and literally build a
personalized emoji message in front of
their eyes just hammer the emojis
together with some nails then apply your
choice of wood varnish or shellac not
only have you gotten your message across
but you've built something with your own
bare hands and that feels good [ __ ] I
got caught up at work I'm not gonna make
lunch yeah sorry love you love you
messages you can build with my
hand-carved wood emojis include but are
not limited to I love you and I love
cats I love you but I'm sad that the cat
pooped and I built you a birdhouse just
kidding but I did make you a salad and
this is just a coat rack how much would
you pay for these hand-carved
painstakingly crafted wooden emojis if
you said $24.99 you were off by just
five bucks per round now if you'll
excuse me I'm gonna send some
flirtatious emojis to my wife cool now
you